alright hey everybody first stream of
the new year was not actually going to
stream today and then I ended up just
with a little bit of time and so we're
going to do it and I want to play for
you some videos related to what's going
on with Iran just casual very very
casual stream I'm going to preview some
of the things we'll be talking about
tomorrow it felt like you know it's
January 5th I don't want to wait too
much longer before getting the first
stream of the year on the record so here
I am so I may open the phones later I
may
I guess I'd consider maybe playing a
little chess against people we are going
to be doing a David Pakman show chess
tournament at some point in the next
month or two and tomorrow we're going to
talk about the right way to set it up
it'll just be for fun I don't expect to
win there are many good chess players in
my audience and it will be an honor
merely to participate but I have no
intention of winning and can't imagine
that I will so we will talk about what's
going on with our allies related to
what's happening in Iran I want to talk
about the justification that's being
used for the assassination that took
place in Iran we have Donald Trump
threatening war crimes very very
casually specifically with these two
words right here on Twitter so we're
going to talk about that and we will
talk about actually the destruction of
cultural sites more generally this is a
war crime and people have actually been
convicted of this and then I've got
Tucker Carlson being you know broken
clock is every once in a while correct
and Tucker Carlson was right about
something I want to look at new polling
because there is some very interesting
new polling which I'm highlighting for
you right now Michael Bloomberg polling
11 in a recent poll and seven in another
and then again maybe will play a little
chess we'll see what happens maybe we'll
open up the phone lines I set a very
modest you know 2019 was a very special
year it was a record year for us in
terms of new members sometimes I would
go completely bonkers and set a new
member goal for streams of like 40
members 45 members I think once we even
hit 448 members or something like that
this is 2020 I don't want to presume
that it's going to go as well so a very
modest goal of 10 new website members
people might say you know David you have
a you have a coupon code up there that
refers to 2019 and it's 2020 well it's a
very strong coupon code that we've been
looking at very strongly for a while and
it still works so I figured I would
leave it there in case people want to
take advantage of it if you are watching
on twitch welcome we are actually I I
think that this month we are going to
see some people be twitch subscribers
for the sixth month in a row I think
that that I think this is a hold on
October November December September
August I don't remember when I started
on twitch maybe we will get some
six-month subscribers but in the
meantime oh there it is
tan man six eight eight nine there are
our first six months subscriber thanks
tan man also thanks to Carbon form and
Moses 526 and Nix the latter and a
sportin and all of these great people I
will be taking super chats over on
YouTube we are on live on YouTube as
well and if folks have questions or
comments about what we're talking about
today feel free to send a super chat so
let's get right into it Donald Trump
assassinated without the congressional
approval that he claimed Barack Obama
needed if he was going to do things in
Syria Donald Trump assassinated the
leader of the Kurds force of Iran Kasim
Soleimani Donald Trump did not consult
or even notify our European allies he
did not consult or notify even our
congressional leaders it seems that
random guests at his mar-a-lago resort
actually knew more to some degree about
what was going to take place in Iraq and
we are now suffering the consequences of
that which are that many of our allies
are starting to abandon us there's a
good piece and Business Insider about
this as you can see here the UK says
further conflict is in none of our
interests Germany is warning of a
dangerous escalation Tom chicken dot the
chairman of the UK Parliament's Foreign
Affairs Committee said to the BBC the
purpose of having allies is that we can
surprise our enemies and not each other
this is not going to go well this is not
going to go well at all and I know that
there is this movement on the right in
the United States this hyper nationalist
movement who thinks you know everything
from we just need to do everything
ourselves and it doesn't matter what our
allies think all the way up to and
including you know what do we care about
what the European sissies want if they
don't like something it's probably good
for us I mean there are people that
disconnected from reality that that's
what they believe and unfortunately we
are seeing the damage that is done when
other countries that are our historical
allies see us as a laughingstock it's
not good
it's ugly we are increasingly out of the
conversation on major issues related to
climate we are increasingly out of the
conversation on major issues related to
trade Donald Trump launching this
unilateral by unilateral I don't mean
china isn't reciprocating I mean you
unilateral in that it's running counter
to what many of our European and other
allies believe would be good this is
this is different than Iraq we're going
to talk actually a lot about the ways in
which the propagandizing around Iran is
very similar to Iraq on tomorrow's
program but one of the ways in which it
is very different is that there was a
coalition we could say it was a toxic
coalition involving neo-cons like tony
blair when it came to iraq but this is
very much the opposite and that's one of
the differences between donald trump and
george w bush not to romanticize george
w bush in any way whatsoever I see a
super chat from azim Abu Khalil who says
Donald disproportionate response Trump
it's not even about a disproportionate
response it's about a completely bogus
justification for what Donald Trump did
and I'm going to get to that in a moment
but you're getting at something up
totally correct also a super chat from a
rich ropa thack
who says will you play me on chess calm
my username is blunder I will I will not
I I will potentially play some folks on
leech s org where I am David Pakman but
I am NOT set up right now to do any
chess over on chess calm on the
livestream
Kelly Lewis walls says what was the
imminent threat required let's talk
about the justification right now
and let me just quickly thank Shane for
subscribing for five months in a row on
Twitch Wharf for subscribing for the
first month very much appreciate that
consider this an invitation to reappear
twitch Prime subs okay so what is the
justification that the White House is
giving for the assassination with no
congressional authorization in Iraq of
the Iranian codes leader Kasim
sulemani the trump administration has
publicly insisted that the u.s.
assassination of Iranian military leader
Qasem Soleimani was justified because he
was planning imminent attacks against
American forces and diplomats in the
region but the White House has yet to
offer a shred of evidence substantiating
this narrative I believe that the
evidence is effectively non-existent now
this is the really interesting thing and
reporter rook mini kalamaki has a good
tweet thread about this and let's just
look at the thread rather than rat
rather than the summary of the thread
this is really really good stuff I've
had a chance to check in with sources
including two US officials who had
intelligence briefings after the strike
on suleimani here's what I've learned
according to them the evidence
suggesting there was to be an imminent
attack on American targets is razor thin
in fact the evidence pointing to that
came as three discrete facts this is the
key tweet a pattern of travel showing
sulemani was in Syria Lebanon and Iraq
to meet with Shia proxies known to have
an offensive position to the US now as
one source said that's business as usual
for sulamani that is not evidence
that an attack was imminent next more
intriguing was B information indicating
sulemani sought the Supreme Leader's
approval for an operation he was told to
come to Tehran for consultation and
further guidance suggesting the
operation was a big deal but again this
could be anything so the question is
what are our standards of evidence you
can say well there's the circumstantial
thing sulemani was in Syria Lebanon and
Iraq and sulemani was looking for the
Supreme Leader's approval that's the
basis on which we do assassinations on
foreign foreign soil without
congressional approval which Donald
Trump said that we needed and then
Remini goes on to say and finally a and
B were read in the context of C Iran's
increasingly bellicose position towards
American interests in Iraq including the
attack that killed the contractor and
the recent protests outside the embassy
of course the entire protest outside the
embassy is something Donald Trump has
uniquely blamed on Iran but the evidence
of that is is lacking Brookman he goes
on to say as one source put it a B and C
is hardly evidence of an imminent attack
on American interests that could kill
hundreds as the White House has since
claimed the official describes the
reading of the intelligence as an
illogical leap one official described
the planning for the strike as chaotic
the official says that the following
that following the attack on an Iraqi
base which killed an American contractor
around December 27 Trump was presented a
menu of options for how to retaliate
killing sulemani was the far out option
Trump chose a more moderate option which
involved the December 29th strikes on
the positions of an Iranian backed
militia then came the protests at the
gates of the US Embassy in Baghdad it
was after the embassy protests that the
president according to one US official
chose the suleimani option but the
problem at that point in time is that
American intelligence did not know his
whereabouts they scrambled to locate him
according to the official the strike on
sulamani was pulled together so quickly
that initially the u.s. was not sure PMF
leader abu mahdi al Mohandas was in the
convoy he was also killed and is viewed
as an Iranian proxy since the strike
Iran has convened its national security
chiefs chatter intercepted by American
intelligence indicates they're
considering a range of options
cyberattacks
under all facilities and American
personnel and diplomatic outposts have
been cited so far I want to look at one
more of these
but among the menu options that I had
not heard before were one kidnapping and
execution of American citizens this
might explain why the State Department
has ordered everybody out another is a
tax on American diplomatic and military
outposts not just in Iraq Lebanon and
Syria but as far afield as UAE and
Bahrain this is going to be extremely
ugly and you know III think that there's
probably people in my audience who are
more interested in talking about the
legal basis for this there's people in
the audience who are interested in
talking about the corporate basis for
this military-industrial complex there's
others who want to talk about tactics
and warfare and you know we could sort
of start anywhere one of the things that
I think we could not possibly talk about
here without including his context is
that Donald Trump pulled out of the Iran
nuclear deal unilaterally meaning are
the other signatories France and others
they didn't pull out and pulled out
without Iran having violated that deal
now you could have opposed that deal to
begin with under Barack Obama that
that's fine actually but I don't I was
in favor of it but you could just say it
was a bad deal to begin with but we lose
credibility internationally when we say
oh here's a treaty under a past
president we're just going to bail for
no reason other than the new president
doesn't like it we are not credible when
we do that and Donald Trump did that now
France came in an Emmanuel macron and
tried to salvage Iran continuing to
abide by the deal if you're Iran and you
abide by the deal and then Trump says
were out even though there are other
signatories to that deal it's probably a
reasonable thing to do from from a game
theory perspective from a geopolitics
perspective foreign relations to get
back to what you were doing because the
United States has bailed on the deal
Emmanuel macron was trying to prevent
that Iran has today announced after this
assassination they are considering
themselves no longer bound by that deal
the United States backed out
they are going forward as if that deal
doesn't exist that which Donald Trump
caused by getting out of the deal and
precipitated perpetuated further with
this assassination Trump will use that
as justification that we need to go into
Iran so much like with Iraq where there
were lies being told and much of the
circumstances that were cited as reasons
to go in were caused by the United
States to begin with that is what they
are going to do they are going to say
listen this is a bad these are bad
actors soleimani was about to run an
operation to kill hundreds of Americans
there's no evidence of that right now
they've now publicly said they're out of
the deal wait a second you said you were
out of the deal a year or however long
ago it was and they will use
circumstances they created to justify
going in that cannot be ignored and that
is a big part of what's going on now I
am no military strategist but over the
last couple days I've been reading a
fair bit about you know it's very
popular in the United States
particularly when you operate under the
assumption that we have the biggest
military and we can take out anybody a
lot of people in the u.s. just assume we
can win any war and often that's true
but the question is at what cost and
Iran would be so different than Iraq
number one Iran's the terrain in Iran is
very very different and it would go in a
completely different way number two
Iran's military is far more powerful
than then it rocks was in 2003
number three Iran actually has some
ability to generate PR campaigns and I
don't know that I would say straight-up
defenders although there may be some but
it from PR perspective it's going to be
very very different so anybody thinking
that this is going to go anything like
like Iraq is is absolutely wrong and
then once again we get to the legality
and we're going to talk about the
legality much more this week so we'll
sort of put a pause on that conversation
next I want to talk about Donald Trump
threatening war crimes on Twitter before
I do that let me just thank a bunch of
people who have been reaping their
twitch prime subscriptions thanks to low
lol tjl for subscribing with twitch
Prime
thanks to HL WD S Corp eoo Scorpio S
Corp EO Scorpio for subscribing with
twitch prime I appreciate that
over on YouTube a couple of other super
chats that have been coming in which I
want to mention actually maybe not maybe
the super chats are few and far between
Kelly sent one but retracted it Ali Ali
says do you think Iran could respond
with regime change in Saudi and UAE
i we're going to talk about the Saudi
UAE component probably probably Tuesday
or Wednesday on the show so let me let
me not preempted at right now by by
addressing it other super chats there's
the scroll is a little weird so I
apologize if I missed any but call my
attention to them let me also say thanks
to a few new members I want to say
thanks to Curt rostec for signing up at
join pakman.com powell ofin it's a-- for
signing up at join pakman.com David Guth
sorry
thanks David I appreciate that and
Thomas christeson so we now have these
great graphics which when I update them
look at this thing look at that we're
almost halfway to me opening up the
phone lines amazing amazing first stream
of the year okay let's continue now it
is a war crime as per the Geneva
Convention it is a war crime to
deliberately destroy sites of cultural
importance cultural heritage etc Donald
Trump is threatening exactly that
casually on Twitter this is a three
tweet rant from Donald Trump yesterday
where Donald Trump says Iran is talking
very boldly about targeting certain USA
assets as revenge for our ridding the
world of their terrorist leader who had
just killed an American and badly
wounded many others not to mention all
of the people he killed over his
lifetime including recently hundreds of
Iranian protesters he was already
attacking our embassy and preparing for
additional hits in other locations Iran
has been nothing but problems for many
years let this serve as a warning that
if Iran strikes any Americans or
American assets we have targeted 52
Iranian sites representing the 52
American hostages taken years ago
weird some at a very high level and
important to Iran and the Iranian
culture and those targets and Iran
itself will be hit very fast and very
hard the USA wants no more threats these
are a debt debt suit that's a threat of
a war crime okay and it's not just a
threat of a war crime in a vacuum it is
actually a threat of a war crime that we
criticized Isis for doing okay
this is a list this is an article on
Wikipedia destruction of cultural
heritage by ISIL okay these are war
crimes it includes mosques and shrines
it includes churches and monasteries
there is an extensive list of these
ancient and medieval sites and it has an
extensive list of them libraries this is
a war crime okay this includes there's
probably more actually than is outlined
just in this article one of the things
that we would say when we would
correctly assess the savagery being
carried out by ISIL we would say they
are willy-nilly going around destroying
sites of cultural significance they're
doing it on purpose and now Donald Trump
is on Twitter threatening the exact same
thing threatening to do that exact same
thing that we cited as evidence of how
bad Isis or ISIL as not as a Barack
Obama liked to call it what what do we
say right I mean I if if you're asking
me do I think if Trump does this Trump
goes to prison for war crimes of course
not of course not but we have you know a
president who is is it's not even really
saying the quiet part out loud I mean
you can say a lot of bad things about
American foreign policy and neo-cons and
all of this stuff but you know publicly
and and deliberately targeting just
random random cultural sites this is
completely outrageous as people in the
chat are suggesting now
I see people saying threatening war
crimes is not the same as committing
them that's exactly right that's exactly
right but we're I feel that that's a
user named Seb de plug this is part of
the normalization you are suffering Seb
de you are suffering from the
normalization that many of us are
suffering from as a result of Donald
Trump which is we have been desensitized
to the insanity where when the president
threatens the same war crimes on Twitter
that would have been at one point
unthinkable to publicly say that we
criticized ISIL for you have people who
are so desensitized that say yeah you
know threatening war crimes is not the
same as committing war crimes I got it
it's not the same but that is the
primary reaction it shows us the depths
of the normalization that I am trying to
fight in 2020 I don't know if people saw
we did shows on we actually did it shows
all week other than on the first and as
I said one of my goals for 2020 is to
not allow insanity to be considered
normal and as other folks are pointing
out additionally even if threatening war
crimes on Twitter is not committing them
it can still escalate a situation
unnecessarily but that maybe Trump's
goal Donald Trump may actually be trying
to escalate the situation and that that
should not be ignored okay let's go now
to Tucker Carlson so let me think how -
I haven't sort of put together my
thoughts and my notes on this for
tomorrow's show tucker carlson is not
someone that i go to if i want for any
kind of rational thought that I'm sort
of struggling here because what's going
on is is so insane
but tucker carlson has an anti
interventionist streak and he has a
nationalist streak and sometimes every
once in a while when it comes to foreign
intervention and wars tucker carlson
will come across a take that makes sense
even if it's motivated by completely the
wrong things oh yeah let me even pause
this because I I see that there are some
super chats and I don't want
to scroll away before I get to read him
Matthew Dominguez says already seeing
everywhere that Iran was responsible for
the embassy attack what is the reality
and do you have sources finding the
truth is rough I have not seen evidence
that Iran is responsible for the embassy
attack and I know that from the get-go
that is what that that is that is what
the Trump administration has been citing
but beyond that I've not seen evidence
of that I see people telling me to check
my notifications on Twitter I I can't do
it I so I only look on Twitter at my
verified feed and if I'm following
people they can direct message me
twitter has become a cesspool and I
there's just no way every time I look
there's hundreds of mentions and I just
it's sad but I can't I'm not doing it
anymore so that is not a good way to get
in touch with me tune in drop out sends
a fifty dollar super chap says Obama's
Iran deal pretty much conceded the
eventualities of an Iranian bomb I don't
agree with that going on to say the
endgame for Trump is to make sure that
Iran's ability to produce a nuclear bomb
is so severely degraded that they know
not longer considered a worthwhile goal
tune in drop out I appreciate the $50 I
don't know if you are at rumpus but
you're ascribing rational calculation to
Donald Trump I've seen no evidence that
he's capable of that Donald Trump
tweeted many times during the Obama
administration that Obama's going to
take us to war with Iran in order to
help himself get reelected I believe
that that's all that's going on Donald
Trump believes that an escalation with
Iran may help him get reelected and it
will distract from impeachment I've seen
no evidence of what you are saying as
the type of thought that Donald Trump is
capable of that that that's just the way
I see it music 55 sends a $20 super chat
question why don't we have guidelines
for our president asked to speak
bilingual languages since there are
dealing since they are dealing with all
other kind of countries and not rely on
interpreters who can interpret the wrong
word listen unfortunately in the United
States if you restrict presidential
candidates to people who can who are
bilingual you are going to
drastically drastically restrict the
number of people and you might actually
keep some some good people out let me
say thanks we're gonna get to this video
I don't want to fall behind on thank
yous gar has subscribed with twitch
prime the mushroom man has subscribed
for four months in a row says love the
show keep it up
ocean OVA subscribed for six months in a
row hey David love you member for nearly
two years
love you too appreciate it Valon blade
OG 85 annoy subscribed for four months
in a row and heard about it says stay
strong David the gaslighting is real it
is very very real alright so let's get
back to Tucker
I'll just play this and actually I don't
have my uh when I plug in my headphones
you may hear a Windows sound when I do
this and I know that that's an
incredibly beta thing for me to do but I
do have to do it we're gonna listen to
Tucker Carlson just making a good point
about what's going on in Iran there we
go and let me turn that down good and
now he's saying this for all the wrong
reasons so so we'll get to that in a
second let's take a listen to this
together we're located in the region
threats in the region if you don't live
in Washington here's the translation
that would be in hostile Middle Eastern
countries places where American troops
would never be in the first place where
it not for the insistent demands of non
geniuses like Max Buddha and John Bolton
but nevermind no one in Washington is in
mood for big-picture questions right now
questions the obvious ones like is Iran
really the greatest threat we face and
who's actually benefiting from this and
why are we continuing to ignore the
decline of our own country in favor of
jumping into another quagmire from which
there is no obvious exit by the way if
we're still in Afghanistan 19 years sad
years later what makes us think there's
a quick way out of Iran and so on nobody
is thinking like that right now instead
chest beaters like senator Ben Sasse of
Nebraska are making the usual warlike
noises the ones they always make this is
very simple Ben Sasse wrote in a
statement last night general Soleimani
is dead because he was an evil bastard
who murdered Americans which is
essentially true Soleimani was certainly
in bad
but does that make killing him quote
very simple it does not nothing about
life and certainly nothing about killing
is ever very simple in any politician
tells you otherwise is dumb or is lying
yes soleimani was linked to the deaths
of Americans nobody mourns his passing
but Mexico and China are also linked to
the deaths of Americans each has flooded
our country with narcotics from which
tens of thousands of Americans die every
single year not that anyone in power
cares so does that mean we get to bomb
Oaxaca
can we start assassinating generals and
the People's Liberation Army
maybe maybe so listen so let's let's
break this down by the way it's really
funny the first comment is I agree with
Tucker about a lot but I don't know
about this know this is one of the few
times Tucker is right but he starts to
get into so so let's break this down
Tucker Carlson is completely right to be
skeptical of a military escalation with
Iran he's just right that we don't have
to anything else we don't have to soften
it in any way we don't have to add
caveats Tucker Carlson is right to be
skeptical about getting involved with
Iran he's right that Soleimani was a bad
guy but does that justify and does that
make it super clear that we need to go
and assassinate him on foreign soil no
however as his being pointed out by
people in the chat
he works in Mexicans like we have our
own problems to deal with well listen
the problems Tucker Carlson wants to
deal with are not the right ones Tucker
Carlson has said before that he doesn't
but he believes white supremacy as a
hoax in the United States okay that's
that's so so that is an issue he doesn't
think it is one Tucker Carlson has said
immigrants make the country dirtier
that's an issue he wants to deal with so
it's a broken clock that's right twice a
day but it happens to be right for the
wrong reasons it's not right because it
just happened to be the time that the
clock stopped at it's right because
someone smashed it on the floor and it
sort of looked like the two hands
aligned fell at the time that it happens
to be right I mean I'm trying to I'm
using the clock analogy he's completely
wrong about all of this other stuff he
says you know we got to be dealing with
Mexico and the the the the people and
the
drugs that are flooding in well we've
got to deal with the reason why which
includes a market for drugs in the US
including the war on drugs it includes
the fact that if we actually worked on
improving the economies of the countries
where people are trying to come here we
would drastically reduce the desire for
people to come here undocumented so
we're gonna dig into this more tomorrow
and it you know I'm I the benefit of
this is this is still Fox News and even
though you get you know people saying oh
I don't know I agree with Tucker about a
lot but I don't know about this it's
still good because it could pierce the
echo-chamber
of some of the people that are watching
on Fox News a thanks to view out one for
subscribing with twitch Prime and toady
Capote for subscribing for the second
month in a row also let's get to some
super chats Sami Ali Aragon says am I
wrong to be fearful of a war on American
soil you know it's it's not super likely
this is likely a war that will be fought
elsewhere that doesn't make it any
better that in fact maybe makes us too
willing to get involved and in if the
United States had to consider the
possibility of war on our soil when we
did this crap our entire foreign policy
would be very different other super
chats Joseph Curtis David I would love
to see you in Destiny hash out some of
your thoughts and differences in regards
to Bernie's policies sometimes glad to
do it anytime
Steven destiny bunnell the second is a
is a friend of mine and I'd be glad to
talk to him about that anytime a
Punisher underscore Stute underscore
2003 is asking for a gift subscriptions
on on Twitch in case anyone wants to
indulge Punisher another super chat from
Kyle McGeehan who says at this point the
default assumption on the part of the
media and the u.s. citizenry should be
that any pretext provided by the
government for war and aggression is a
lie no war on Iran yeah I mean it's hard
to think of own Ickx the latter just a
gifted a sub to punisher I can't think
of a recent military engagement where we
were just told the truth
I mean you know I guess in some ways
with Isis right but even there there
there were lies told I don't know it's
it's very depressing let's see okay that
catches me up on super chats let me
thank some new members Zoey Oliva thank
you for becoming a member at join
pakman.com and oh I think that that's
the only new member yeah okay so that
gets us to five and the bar goes up
there go very nice and the the person
who did the new graphics for us is
actually working on some new ones for
the interviews that I do so that info
about that upcoming and we will I don't
have a ton of time today but the way
things are going if we were to quickly
get to ten I would open up the phone
lines for a little bit okay let's
continued let's do a little bit on so
almost the entire show tomorrow is going
to be iran-related
so I wanted to get on to a few other
things there's very very interesting new
polling going on in a few different ways
and I'm just going to tell you what the
polling says this is not indicative of
what I want the reality to be or any of
that crap okay I'm just telling you
what's going on so number one let me see
if I can zoom this out so that we can
all see there we go
okay so we're seeing a couple things
going on recently much to the dismay of
many progressives Joe Biden has been
over the last three weeks
sorry solidifying his support but as you
see it's been like an EKG you know it's
been up down up down so we don't
necessarily know what's going to happen
Bernie Sanders after kind of bottoming
out around 15 percent has been
recovering and he is up to nearly 20 he
is much more solidly the second-place
candidate now than he was before when he
was going back and forth with all
Lizabeth Warren Elizabeth Warren has not
been doing well Elizabeth Warren had
nearly tied for first with Joe Biden
back in October and had one decline a
second decline and now sort of has
balanced out a little bit we're going to
look at state-by-state polling because
this is soon going to be a situation
where it is
going to be individual primaries but I
want to talk about Michael Bloomberg I
don't think that we need a warren
president a billionaire president not a
war in president Freudian slip maybe I
don't believe that we need a billionaire
president but I am very interested in
how Michael Bloomberg has been able to
combine money and some public notoriety
to actually do well in polls where as
Tom Steyer has not been able to Tom
Steyer still at where is he one point
nine percent so let's now look at the
recent polling for Michael Bloomberg
Michael Bloomberg polling 11 in a recent
Hill poll stunning then only polling 3
in the Economist and then polling seven
in a Harris Poll whether Bloomberg is
really polling 7 or 11 or 6 or just an
average of these numbers which gets us
to five point six it's already extremely
interesting because of the sort of
quagmire that it puts the DNC in when it
comes to what to do about the debates
and we've already heard from Tom Perez
that let's see if we can even find let
me pull up that info 2020 democratic
debates wiki that's the primary wiki let
me get the debates wiki up yep here we
go so as you remember let's look at
sixth debate now seventh debate yeah
here it is okay so so far the
qualifications are that you need to meet
a donor criteria you need to meet a
four-pole criteria and you need to meet
early State polling criteria now of
course because Michael Bloomberg is not
accepting donors he cannot meet the
donor criterion for getting into these
debates so the question is starting with
the eighth debate is something going to
change so that Michael Bloomberg could
conceivably get in now I'll be totally
upfront with you
number one it would be nuts now to
change all the rules in order to let
michael bloomberg n because especially
when it's because he's right he's spent
a lot of money and basically bought
polling support if i were the other
candidates i would be furious because if
all along the requirements had been
different the other candidates could
have managed their spending differently
if they didn't have to worry about the
number of donors that they have at the
same time i recognize that if indeed
michael bloomberg is polling five point
six percent that's more than yang that's
more than Klobuchar that's more than
Booker that's more than Tulsi who I
think is not even making any of the
debates anymore so it's weird for him
not to be there if he has support at the
same time if he's bought his support do
we really consider that grassroots I
don't I don't know what's going to
happen I think either way the DNC is in
an unenviable position but and no matter
what they do it's going to be a problem
I don't know I see people in the chat
saying it's good for Bernie if Bloomberg
is at the debate I don't know if it is I
don't I don't know if it's good I don't
know who it's good for it's good for
Michael Bloomberg that I can tell you so
we'll see what happens with that a
Francisco Martinez says via super chat
Bernie has appeared on other shows like
Joe Rogan have you tried setting up an
interview with Bernie Sanders yes I've
emailed with Bernie's campaign manager
feds I think is his name and I think he
was giving me kind of a blow-off like
yeah we'll let you know would love to
have Bernie on anytime
Sam V says hey I just tuned in do you
think it outlandish to suspect that
orchestration of Trump presidency was in
large part to set up a puppet who would
go to war with Iran you know oftentimes
there's simpler explanations than we
need and I don't think you know much
like the idea that there was a
fifty-year for you know 44-year or
whatever a conspiracy to get a guy who
is not eligible to be President Barack
Obama to be President it's just way more
complicated a theory than the
circumstances suggest it's sort of the
same thing with Trump I think that Trump
didn't think he was going to win and
then all of a sudden you know you you
can't really underestimate the
intelligence of the Republican
electorate he was all of a sudden in a
position to actually get in and then
foreign powers realized it would be kind
of useful and funny and make the u.s. a
laughingstock of Trump one so they
helped I don't think you need to go to
something so so so concocted in advance
in this way some body says wars are
wrong until Trump says it's okay this is
like an irrational father coming home
and making illogical decisions in the
family just going with it it very much
is like that and the sort of
dysfunctional family analogy or metaphor
is probably a good one when it comes to
a lot of Trump support let's see people
if you're people asking why I don't
answer all the Super chats I'm answering
all of the ones that I see I'm answering
all of the ones that I see let me say
thanks to Jonathan McCall for signing up
at join pakman.com also Alana Schulte
Schulz Schulte Denver McCarthy has
signed up as well thanks Denver very
much appreciate that that gets us to
nine of ten new members we are almost
there I will open up the phone lines for
a little bit if we get to ten we have
this this membership special this
membership special is so good it's
considered illegal in some southern
states but we're still offering it at
risk of being sued it you saved 66% with
the coupon last 2019 it was meant to be
like an end of 2019 coupon code but I
forgot to close it out so it still works
and I guess I'm mentioning it today and
people can use it and take advantage of
it let me say thank you to some folks
who have signed up with twitch prime
Shamar Eve subscribed for three months
in a row seventy six boost left need
boost that the usernames so long it's
going off screen thanks for the cheer
sally x jelly has subscribed for two
months in a row Nick's the latter has
gifted a tier one sub to death saw
eternal Claymore has subscribed for
three months in a row and Nick's the
latter also gave out a tier 1 sub to
punisher 2003 thanks very much very
generous of you young dumb and baroque
loved that username yum young dumb and
borough
says via super chat look how we
escalated tensions with Iran for a
contractor but we've give arms to Saudi
who has committed genocide on Yemen
killed a u.s. resident journalist yeah
so you need to understand you you need
to understand the dynamics that go
beyond just okay our position is we are
against we are against religiously based
theocratic dictatorships okay well no
that doesn't that doesn't apply
we are against those who carry out
certain types of it's no that doesn't
work either what is the principle oh
that's right we are not for or against
anything because of any kind of
principles beyond we have some
relationships that are profitable and
that are calculated and some that are
not and are used for propaganda purposes
as needed that's really the principle
that you need to understand Payton Pelin
says I was very introverted seeing
progressive voice do an entire live
video bashing you how do you handle that
kind of ridiculous criticism from the
left I didn't see it I don't even know
what you're talking about that's the
funny thing I don't need I don't know
when this happened but I don't watch any
other pull so on my personal YouTube
account which is the one I use to browse
YouTube I have told the algorithm don't
even show me any political channels
anytime something political comes on I
say I don't want to see stuff from this
channel and the algorithm knows that I'm
not watching any political stuff so I
don't get any recommendations I don't
know what anybody's saying about me
unless you know people email me
sometimes I'll see or if a verified user
sends me a tweet or something like that
so I basically handle it just by doing
my thing and I've been on vacation for a
lot of the last 12 days or so so I don't
know what you're referring to but the
way I handle it is I just don't pay
attention and I just do my show and do
the best I can and as a result we had
not by a little bit we had but by a lot
our best year ever in 2019 and we are
closing in on let me see here we're
closing in on 800,000 subscribers on
YouTube which is
amazing and we've got a lot of good
stuff going on by the way let me mention
if people are interested in checking out
a new platform and I you know YouTube is
a great platform for us twitch is a
great platform for us I'm very careful
about promoting new platforms we test
out our content a lot of places but then
sometimes it doesn't work out and we
just bail kind of like with Jordan
Peterson's think spot thing but we're on
a new platform that is actually very
cool it's called library but it's
abbreviated lb ry and if you go to lb ry
TV you can get an account for free you
can just search for my name you'll find
our channel there we are mirroring all
of our content there we can we get paid
just for you watching our videos there's
no algorithm that's like okay David
Pakman I don't know this doesn't seem
authoritative we're not gonna run an ad
and therefore David Pakman won't get
paid just for watching our content we
get rewards in an on platform currency
if you follow us once we get to certain
numbers of followers we get financial
incentives so check it out I spent some
time on it over the new and we're going
to be talking about it more on the show
but check it out lbr y dot TV I'd be
curious to see what what folks think
about it Ryan Harrison says how what
would have to happen for the states to
invoke the nato clause to bring in other
countries as they did after 9/11
if you mean if if what would have to
happen in order to bring in o or people
saying that my stream is down oh no
everything seems okay sorry about that
if you're saying what would have to
happen for the for NATO to be pulled in
to attack Iran with the United States I
don't think that's going to happen in
this case whatsoever if I misunderstood
then apologies let me know Ryan Sieber
says what product do you use in your
hair okay I'll tell you but they don't
sponsor me or anything I use a product
called American Crew it's called fiber
and it's a fantastic product I've been
using it for 10 years i I've only ever
gotten one bad batch and I actually got
it a week ago it was a gummed up like
I don't know like something not good but
it's a great product the great thing
about it is it basically makes my hair
pliable I'm not gonna do it because it
would get a little crazy well I'll try
it let's see you can basically see that
it starts to just stay in the position I
put it in let me see here yeah it's
actually this is not a good example but
there we go
this is what I'm talking about it
doesn't like it's it's pliable but it
still holds and it doesn't look wet
which is exactly what I prefer from a
good good hair product yeah there we go
so anyway I'm doubting that this is
exactly what would make American fiber
think that is a good advertisement for
their product but that's that's why I
use it and it's a it's a tremendous
product Jason Ealing is asking how was
your holiday it was really good so as
some people know and if you follow me on
Instagram you would know I was in London
and Paris and Paris was interesting you
know they have strikes going on and it
was a sort of different different scene
there than than what we are often used
to seeing in Paris but it was a great
time London I had a great time I went
this is a kind of a funny thing I was
visiting a bunch of friends there and
some other friends were visiting Paris
London rather and we were there on
Christmas Day and a lot of things are
closed on Christmas Day in Paris so we
made a reservation at a kosher Chinese
restaurant and it was an incredible
experience and it's sort of not
appropriate maybe for this stream but it
was just an amazing amazing experience
other super chats
Kumiko says jumped in late forgive me if
you've answered this think any of these
recent events with Iran will effect
Republican senators view on Trump I
haven't addressed that I think that they
are basically going to get in line with
Donald Trump by and large I don't think
Trump is going to have much Republican
opposition to whatever he wants to do in
Iran okay let me say thanks to a few
other folks over on Twitch thanks to
jellybean zero five to six for
subscribing for the
month in a row with the message your
show is my happy place
thanks to origins and tall tales for
cheering the some bits as well as
Shamari
V Pearson 252 has subscribed with twitch
Prime mr. hollow tree has subscribed
with twitch Prime bolo 510 second month
in a row with the message Pakman 2020
thank you very much appreciate that okay
I see that there are new members so
we'll open up the phone lines in a
second Keith bajina has signed up Dustin
Dekker has signed up Larry Hudson Rachel
Phil Amir that's four and is there
anybody else here Joseph Curtis is five
Kevin Knowles is six and okay I think
that's it so that gets us to 15 fifteen
of of ten members let's just make the
new goal twenty five but I'm still gonna
open up the phone lines I'm still gonna
open up the phone lines let me get that
going and then I do still have a few
other super chats to answer won't be a
long stream it's my first day back from
being out of town and I've got a lot of
lot of work to do but I will take a few
phone calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 if
people want to call in I'm going to just
answer a few other questions that are
coming in Marwick 20 says with their
twitch Prime signup Pakman V destiny
debate when I talk I talked to destiny
on stream frequently so you know
sometimes we disagree I don't know if we
call it a debate per se a thanks to
gizmo girl 85 for subscribing with
twitch prime as well as well as the
worst CA for subscribing with the
hashtag bring back Lewis Lewis is long
gone Lewis is in his own world at this
point
thanks to bride clutch for subscribing
for five months in a row as well very
much appreciate that
ok let's get set up for phone calls I
will keep reading off messages that come
in via twitch prime or via super chats
whoa 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the number to
call if you are
interested in getting off the phone with
me we've got a bunch of a bunch of our
friends I see who are already holding
and maybe we will we will make some new
friends
let's see here if I can get connected
here we go
thank you for calling in to the David
Pakman show
please do not use speakerphone have your
question ready and listen for David to
call out your area code good advice
a great gree bow is saying via super
chat that I should consider sending my
own hair product to Donald Trump that is
an idea that's definitely an idea that I
would I would I would I would consider
that very very strongly ZT any press
subscribed for four months in a row and
twitch Prime and says Dave have you seen
the movie the report on Amazon
what could a progressive president do to
right some of the wrongs in that movie I
haven't seen it so I would not be able
to say I would not be able to say okay
let's go first to Grayson Grayson is a
13 year old who was deprogrammed and
then turned 14 you're still 14 right
Grayson yeah yeah I transformed very
nice how was that was your heart of the
Grayson oh I don't feel great Hanukkah
but it was good all right now you know
how I feel when people rush me Merry
Christmas
yeah I'm generally against that it kind
of annoy me everyone's like going
all-out for Christmas that's cool
it was kind of weird but I'm kidding
around anyway what's up what's going on
yeah go ahead my question is kind of
longer so can I just say everything
before it gets answered that's fine all
right that's good but because I already
have 30 people holding just with peace
and love all right
yeah give me the most concise version of
it yeah all right yeah so um so common
progressive argument against public
option I'm not really for it but it's
just argument against it is that the
insurance companies will offload people
with conditions and everything on to the
on to the government system but like
sense recisions were really outlawed
than the 2010 ACA like how do you agree
with that and do you think that'll
actually happen sorry I'm not
understanding the question get
you ask it once again in a different way
alright sorry so a common progressive
argument against having a public option
is that like the insurance companies
will offload everyone with like like
princess and conditions or basically
that need it and to have like a pure
more pure insurance pool with younger
and healthier people um and and I don't
and I don't see how they could really do
that in a mass scale now that recisions
are like of basically getting to kicking
people off the plan for like
whole-hearted reasons are really
outlawed like you can only get kicked
off your contract for like fraud or like
not paying your premiums yeah I mean
listen as if if you add so I agree with
you that I don't think a public option
is the way but if you keep the existing
framework and just add a public option
you wouldn't companies would not be
allowed to deny coverage on the basis of
pre-existing conditions so unless that
changes then you're completely right
that it's not so you don't think so you
don't think I'd like they'll mass load
everyone and stress the public system
and they'll really fail because that's
what people like how kolinsky say and
many other people it's not legal on
something would have to change to make
that legal it's not legal under the
current law alright and also and also
you said you would like a Medicare for
All system to compete against the
private health care and not just outlaw
it real quick would you would in your
ideal system would you have them be a
complementary system but even though
that's led to imperfections and wait
times in Australia then working together
and I know when I say I I don't want I
don't want a Medicare for All system or
any single-payer system to compete with
private insurance what I've said before
is I think outlawing private insurance
is not a good thing to do in that it
would be difficult legally I think we
are better off just allowing private
insurance to increasingly be for whoever
you know in like in other countries
people who say I just want to pay for
private insurance it would be far more
expensive because the pool of people who
want it would become smaller and smaller
this would make it you like yeah I feel
like we begin the same we're laughing
like in Australia they
the government's like subsidizing
private insurance and once everyone on
it I'm afraid something like that will
happen and be two wait times in
impurities in the system but well I know
I thought you're saying you wanted to
like people will overall just choose a
Medicare for All system and like
somewhat compete but I'm taking up too
much time uh next time I'm gonna have
some questions about the the truth about
tax system like the hour long thing but
thank you okay all right Grayson very
good to hear from you and very Happy New
Year let's go next to Ruth from the
nine-oh-nine area code Ruth what's new
with you in 2020 oh boy Ruth you're
you're completely chopped up it's like
it's like you're chopped up like someone
would chop up a carrot on a cutting
board
can you oh boy now you press the button
now I'm curious Ruth did you just press
are you on a run on a regular like a
home like a landline because you just I
just heard a button pressed
oh boy
I know it's okay is that better you know
what is I'm curious what did you do that
matter good I took you off speakerphone
I'm so sorry listen let me just get to
my question here I agree with you is
insane
so why can't we 5150 him since he
presents a danger to others it is 5150 a
medical thing like to do involuntarily
committed yes if they present a danger
to themselves or others and you clearly
present the dangers to others
Ruth are you yelling I'm trying yeah I'm
sorry am I talking too loud no no no no
you just seem so fired up I love the
passion well yes because it's so obvious
to me is so stupid I mean we can why is
that he's above the law above all reads
if somebody presents a danger to others
and he presents a danger to so many
others but millions let's say why can't
we 5150 him and get him out of there
before it like blows us all up yeah well
I have a feeling that when the police
show up Secret Service will stop them
you know I'm just looking for ways to
deal with him with the law you know what
I'm saying David you know Ruth you know
what he masters you know in the power at
this point you know the fastest way to
get this guy out right vote him out in
less than ten months except for but if
the polls are rigged again well then we
have to overwhelm the polls by so much
that it won't make a difference well
what if I mean now that World War three
is starting what if we're all blown up
before then that's what I'm well afraid
of in this point you know what he's not
then we don't have to work then we're
dead and we don't have to worry about it
that's true there's any good life right
well hey look I'm up there trying David
and I'm glad that you are too god bless
him and just keep the faith that's what
I'm doing
all right thank you so much thank you so
much Ruth very much appreciate the phone
call great to hear from Ruth a few super
chats f majors biggest fan says hey
David want to be friends sure could
always use more friends a HOD Hassan
says anyone got any tips on how to dodge
the draft asking for a friend
yeah I think I'm too old to be drafted
right somebody tell me I must be too old
to be drafted at this point in time let
me say thanks to Ariel Garcia as well as
Nob heck for signing up at join
pakman.com taking advantage of just an
obscenely good coupon code that gets us
up to 17 new members for the day got a
rub got a love Ruth very very fired up
very much appreciate it
let's go next - oh let's go to Nick from
Boston Nick from Boston what's going on
Nick from Boston do you have us muted
hmm actually wanted to hear from Nick
from Boston but it doesn't it's not
working
Nick I'm gonna give you one more shot
we're talking to you but we can't hear a
damn thing all right too bad wanted to
hear from undead from Boston let's go -
all right well let's check in with AHS
last time he was on and he told us about
his four duis people were not thrilled
but they felt bad for oz oz what's
what's going on with you in the new year
hello yeah hello there you go what's
going on yeah I was just calling to
voice my outrage
oh the illegal assassination of general
Soleimani I'm sober right now cheated by
where I quit I'm back on the wagon I'm
glad to present this I mean this this
situation has really sobered me up too
but it's like we're watching a bad rerun
by the post 9/11 military reaction no
yeah I saw the same neocon establishment
war mongers that the swamp creatures are
the same ones that were backed in that
surround that are surrounding Trump and
he's just more unstable but it's
disgusting it's disgusting to watch
every mainstream media outlet from Fox
to BBC to MSNBC pumping out to blatant
disinfo and propaganda right I mean it's
just it's obvious I mean it's like
watching that movie they live like it's
like our glasses are on just instantly
now so I'm terrified because I know the
Cabal is so psychotic in order to
control the ones that control this
system that they will most likely I
think they're gonna stage false flag
attacks on American soil to rally us
behind they're a theocratic corporate
socialist agenda I know I just I don't
know that they need to do that I don't
know that they're going to need to do
that to manufacture enough consent
because they don't need to manufacture
that much at this point to get get this
thing going yeah it's just Trump is just
finalizing the pean Act the project for
the new American Century I mean why is
Congress but but but interestingly but
here's the operations that's the day in
in 2003 with Iraq we were talking about
the pinna crowd and the neo cons and all
this stuff I think Trump is just trying
to take attention away from impeachment
and to get himself reelected and it why
not Iran I mean Iran sounds good
well I do I believe I agree with that
but I also think Trump is just being
manipulated and there's I mean he's just
the business WWF and reality TV and
there's way more sinister things behind
Trump that are supporting him and that I
mean pants I heard pence was the one
that talked Trump into this
but I mean these are these are corporate
socialists theocrats and that's the same
regurgitated narrative for every single
excuse to destroy these countries every
time whether it's Libya or Iraq and now
Iran and this is the Iran is no joke
I mean I was in the Marine Corps and I
know people that have been in Special
Forces and also Army Rangers and Iran
it's twice the size of Iraq and we've
made it we've actually looks like we've
managed to outrage these all these
different factions that were adversaries
geez I got you now is listen I think I
think you've made your point you're
hitting a lot of different things here
so I think I got one last thing I just
wonder we we got to face the reality
that that's simply voting them out I'm
saying peaceful means but we got to face
reality the voting them out maybe a
fantasy I mean the corruption is so
systemic and so deep I mean they have
total control of everything I mean yes
not that's true but listen but listen
did this sometimes people take that to
say you know doesn't really matter if
you vote and it does we can overwhelm
the voter disenfranchisement if we turn
out in force and I don't want anybody to
think that voting doesn't make sense
well Bernie Sanders is the only
candidate out there that speaking the
truth right now nobody else has got my
truth but as far as the foreign particle
critics of all this in my opinion and I
just think that he's uh I mean he's the
only one that came out with you know and
actually called it an assassination I
mean everyone else does not to downplay
about that and kind of Oz thank you so
much listen points all well made and I
very much appreciate hearing from you
let's try once more with Nick from
Boston Nick was I don't know what was
going on before we couldn't hear Nick
but Nick's back hey dude can you hear me
now or yes I can i I can hear you fine
oh yeah that was weird I triple-checked
that wasn't me turn or anything but I
mean here man how you doing I quite
thank you good yes I was wondering if
you saw this reporting from I forgot his
name is from the Washington Post basic
claiming that
the Iraqi Prime Minister is claiming
that Trump asked him to mediate with
Iran on our behalf
let's see a mad mind everything that's
all money went down I'm not finding that
article is it mrs. Iraqi leaders call
for foreign troops to leave no that
doesn't sound like a no bottom line I
have not seen that article so I would
not be able to comment on it yeah no
that's fine um basically you know if
that is the case if Trump asked you know
Barack to mediate on our behalf and then
we go back and basically do this do you
think that changes the playing field at
all in terms of how this is it
definitely realigns the framing of
everything that's going on I still think
it does nothing whatsoever about the
assassination and Donald Trump potential
determination to create an escalation
for the benefit of his reelection and
distracting from impeachment I don't
think it would change any of that yeah
absolutely not
I'm just playing terms like the
international stage I think it would
definitely it would be different it
would be different but I would say the
article so I can't say too much more
about it all right yeah keep an eye out
for it
keeping we were doing David take it easy
all right thanks Nick good to hear from
you let's see oh I just got disconnected
from my own phone system let me get
reconnected that was weird I think I
hung up on myself thank you my own
connection was Navy attackman show
please do not use speakerphone have your
question ready and listen for David to
call out your area code oh boy alright
let me get myself reconnected here if I
may
hmm something weird may be going on with
the phone system all right let's see if
this works let's try our caller from the
4:08 area code who's calling today from
four zero eight four zero eight hello
four zero eight can you hear it
yeah all right maybe turn that down that
turning that down might be good yes it
is so I had a quick question I'm Danny
by the way actually with Michigan even
though my phone numbers in California it
seems like the markets don't seem to be
e pricing they don't seem to think that
war with Iran is very likely the oil oil
prices are at the same level as they
were in September when the drone strike
knocked out half of Saudi oil refining
capacity and I'm wondering why you think
that is are we overreacting to how
likely this is I actually think that
it's a more general phenomena that we're
seeing which is when Donald Trump got
impeached the markets moved very little
and in fact had a few good days at the
end of 2019 I believe that the the
aratus ism of Trump is so a baked in
that it's not that the market doesn't
think there's going to be conflict with
Iran it's not that the market isn't
concerned about a trump impeachment it's
that we're we're these things are being
telegraphed in advance and are being
priced in earlier than the discreet
public events are taking place and so it
makes it much harder to say the markets
are reacting this way or that way to an
event because the a lot of these events
we sort of learn about far in advance
and so I think we're operating in a
completely new eye on a new playing
field altogether here ok thanks very
much great to hear from
let me let me say thank you to a few
other folks over on Twitch origins and
tall tales has subscribed for three
months which I very much appreciate
Rhapsody's on Graz has subscribed for
four months with twitch Prime thanks so
much
consider this an invitation to re-up
your twitch Prime subscription s has
sent a super chat saying I just want you
to say veggie to go Bernie alright I
hope that I hope I did it evened Meyer
says hey have some Norwegian kroner to
fund your broken health care system
directly from our petroleum fund social
democracy my friend social democracy
alive and well alive and well there okay
let's see let's try our caller from the
six one nine area code who's calling
today from six one nine yes this is Ryan
and I had a question in regards to the
recent airstrikes that killed that
Iranian general good the House of
Representatives possibly bring up a
third article of impeachment against
don't come in regards to that yes I mean
listen I don't think it's going to
happen but they could and I've been
seeing a lot of articles about this I
there's a case to be made that the
impeachment that was done against Donald
Trump was arguably not the strongest
what with emoluments what with the Yemen
Fiasco and this could be another Ella
art article of impeachment I don't
believe that we will see it though but
certainly that is something the House of
Representatives could do yeah you know
in all honesty I you know I totally
agree I totally agree it may not happen
but if it does more power to them
because it's if something yes it is
absolutely an utterly insane I agree
with you all right well thank you so
much for taking my call and you have a
wonderful rest of your weekend
and thank you so much for what you do
all right thank you so much great to
hear from you Cheryl Alvarez says via
super chat thanks for the Sunday stream
by the way who's your Super Bowl pic now
that the Patriots are out yeah very
depressing game yesterday for the
Patriots I'm probably going with the
49ers and I know that I I know that a
lot of people will probably be furious
for reasons I don't know I mean people
just seemed generally furious about
everything I say but growing up I like
the 49ers in addition to the Patriots in
the 90s I always liked the Niners over
the Cowboys and that rivalry and I love
San Francisco so I don't you know but
who cares I don't even really but now
that the Patriots are out I don't really
care that much one way or the other
Demon's gonzo has subscribed with twitch
prime which I appreciate thank you so
much I also want to say thanks to brandy
Smith brandy Smith just signed up on my
website and becomes new member number 18
of the day let's go oh I saw a possible
local caller let's go to our caller from
the 508 area code caller from 508 what's
your name were you calling from
hey David this is Tyler and my aunt yes
you are Tyler oh great well first I just
want to thank you actually because you
were a question on one of my finals
exams at UMass Amherst on my
communication class we had a question
about your ad pocalypse video so I got
it shut up is that true so whose class
was that in professor Emily West
communication once I had an email
exchange with Emily hold on a second let
me I'm just searching through my email
here that is hilarious
you know I ran into her once at a you
know a salon cafe it's in Hadley oh okay
no I'm not familiar with it oh wow okay
you should really check it out in any
case I ran into her there and she came
up to me and said hey didn't you go to
UMass I know you I know your show that
is very so what was the context that she
had mentioned shows affected by ad
pocalypse or something like that oh yes
so you were actually one of our course
materials throughout the year so it's
kind of expecting that this could
possibly be
a question and it turns out that it was
wow it was a multiple-choice question I
can't remember the exact you know
specifics of it but I do remember that
was one of the ones that I got right I
got a 98 on the final well I'm glad and
whatever role I was able to play that I
appreciate that sure I do have one
question yeah so I don't know if you saw
the to CBS polls that it seems like we
had a shortage of early State polling
especially but we just had to come out
of Iowa and New Hampshire and of course
the big story is the Clovis our search
7% no no no but actually there's a big
qualification a lot of people are now
saying that because of this like
shortage of polling that you know maybe
the DNC should extend the requirements
and I'm kind of against this even though
I kind of do see where they're coming
from just I feel like we've had way too
many candidates on the stage I'm pretty
sure you agree with that as well I
generally agree we've had too many
candidates on the stage yeah and so
where you stand do you think like the
qualification requirement should be
lowered given the shortage of polls out
recently you know I saw that Andrew yang
was saying something about that I I
don't tend to think so
although I so here's the thing I am not
comfortable with the fact that there
have been very few recent polls in some
of these early States but there's no
shortage of national polls and I don't
think that there's any big in so like
let me put in a different way is there a
candidate that you believe should be on
the stage who will not be on the basis
of the way that the requirements are
established right now so no what I think
is that it's after six national debates
you know six chances on national
television to make your case if you're
still pulling a you know five percent
then I find it really difficult to you
know resonate with where you're coming
from and you know I can see where
they're coming from they're like oh well
you know we haven't had the chance to
like adequately measure the post six the
date effect but we've had five other
today's to do that as well and if you're
still pulling at an anaemic you know
three point three percent which some
candidates are at
then I find it really hard to see why
you should be occupying so much time on
stage when there's other candidates
Buddha judge Warren Sanders Biden who
are actually going to be you know
serious competitors in these early
States so based on what you're saying it
sounds like you're saying you want yang
off the stage you want clover char off
Booker off debarred off Scott like every
you you would just want Biden Sanders
Warren Budaj edge and would you want
Bloomberg because he's at 5.6 no I
wouldn't I do like the requirement that
they put in about the fundraising donors
I think that's a good touch to add to it
so that you know billionaires can
essentially just buy their way onto the
stage right now maybe we could adjust it
I'll have to see a stronger argument for
it I don't see why someone should be
allowed on the stage for a seven-time if
after six times they're still polling at
3% well I'm open to of course hearing
other people's thoughts on that all
right we're good well let's see if
anybody else arrives with a different
point of view I'm curious to see that
all right well thank you for taking my
call appreciate it you have a great new
year all right you too thank you all
right before I take the next call we are
starting to see incipient anti-semitism
in the chat and I need to just drop the
banhammer on a few people so just excuse
me for a moment
the bans are free and we will we will
use them folks no question about that
let me say thanks to Don Buerkle Don
Buerkle is new member number 19 of the
evening and I very much appreciate that
let me also say thank you to Dino sore
chol for subscribing for six months uh
with twitch and okay I already thanked
everybody else over there also a super
chat from s do you have faith in the
American public to do their part if and
after Bernie is elected will people stay
engaged enough go Bernie it's not about
whether I have faith it's a question of
whether the president keeps them engaged
and my sense is that Bernie Sanders is a
president that would keep the people
engaged although I've been wrong before
let's go next to our caller from the
four zero one area code maybe from our
friendly neighbors to the south in in
Rhode Island hi can you hear me yes
oh all right I'm actually from Plymouth
so I moved oh so I just want to say um
there's another part of the story
regarding something Iran that's never
talked about really okay came upstairs
and it's a fact that um just a few weeks
ago Nancy Pelosi gave Trump how much was
that one hundred and fifty billion
dollars more yeah for the military
budget and then she stripped away a
bunch of amendments that could have
potentially stopped these preemptive
strikes against Iran especially
concerned the fact that he pulled out of
the Atlantic deal a week up here a
couple of years ago so she could have
seen this coming
and potentially done her part right well
listen there's no question that there
are a lot of Democrats who have been
perpetuating the indefinite growth of
the military and military spending that
there's no question about that how
specifically is what happened a few
weeks ago something that if it had gone
a different way could have prevented
these specific this has I mean Trump did
this without authorization so he ignored
whatever requirements
he believed under Barack Obama were in
place that he needed to to abide by
right so I don't how would that have
made a difference it's a combination of
things and it's also you know the fact
that I'm going way back that she didn't
hold
George Bush or Dick Cheney or Donald R M
so accountable for any war crimes yes so
you know the people in power they just
get this idea that they can do whatever
they want and they get away with it
scot-free because we have incompetent
leadership against from from both sides
of the aisle you know both Democrats and
Republicans so these you know the
executive branch gets more powerful
every year and that you know that leads
to fascism so I don't think it's
everybody's [ __ ] outrage that Donald
Trump but we really have to take a look
at the bigger picture which is both
leadership from Democrats and their lack
of responsibility for holding IIM powers
in agreement with you that we we can't
and we shouldn't excuse Democrats for
looking away on the same things we
criticize Republicans for I completely
agree with you this unauthorized
unhinged assassination though it's it's
it was Donald Trump's decision and he
didn't even notify congressional leaders
and at a certain point we have to make
sure that we are dividing the criticism
in proportion to what is deserved and I
think there are many criticisms of Nancy
Pelosi over the last many years you're
not wrong about what you're saying I
just don't think that in this particular
case of what what took place a few weeks
ago would have prevented Donald Trump
from doing this he did this without
talking to anyone and without
authorization by definition putting in
full stop I don't know that I find it
necessary to even say more than that so
what how and how do we prevent this
going forward and the fact that the
afghan papers came out just a couple
weeks ago and there's been nothing in
the media that should have been like
some national and international scandal
yeah and it was just a blip a couple
people talked about it on independent
media but this type of stuff keeps
happening
I honestly you know I'm only 33 but I
don't I see my nieces and nephews who
were just a few years old and I can see
them
being enlisted potentially draft in the
wars when they get older you know 15 16
years because there's these wars are
never gonna end unless we have something
dramatic changes yeah right hello okay
that's weird
your listen you're talking about a lot
of different things I agree with a lot
of what you're saying I think we don't
want to conflate and you know there are
wrong times to talk about oh but what
about this other person that's my my
only point here Isaac says via super
chat the correct way to pronounce Iran
is Iran very good I'm glad we were able
to clarify that let's go next to our
caller from the 707 area code who's
calling today from 7:07 eyes with me
yeah
uh my name is Jade Patterson I was
wondering what you think our course of
action should be to get Medicare for all
paths once we get a progressive in
office and more specifically I was
wondering if you believe that Warren is
right and postponing a push for Medicare
for all
until her third year in office or do you
believe more so on what I believe
Bernie's plan is which is to put
continued pressure onto politicians
until it is more possible to get
Medicare for all paths and just continue
activism and not keep our focus on that
so I listen I've taken a lot of heat
recently for what I believe is a more
realistic take on what it will what it
what will be required to pass Medicare
for also my view would be I would want
the President to immediately upon
inauguration start mobilizing towards
Medicare for all or some single-payer
system that is actually like Medicare
for all we can't just call anything
Medicare for all and pretend that it is
yeah so it is conceivable I mean listen
if we don't have the Senate we're not
passing Medicare for all in the full way
that I would like to see that doesn't
mean I would just wait till year three
there are things that could be done
right away I think the idea of
immediately going to the to the nation
and saying I promised that Medicare for
all would be one of my top things and
I'm starting today and here is what I
want you to do I need you to do they
call it so I I would be for working on
it immediately and I recognize that if
we don't take the Senate in 2020 I would
bet almost anything I have that it
doesn't happen up if and until we take
the Senate in 2022 but that doesn't mean
nothing can be done
so would I wait until year three if we
don't have the Senate no I wouldn't but
I would say okay I'm going to insist
that Medicare for all is what I want I
am going to bear in mind what is it more
likely that could be done I would look
at whether at the state level you
could do single-payer in a few places
and start getting that moving that would
be interesting to do I would see if
Medicare for all losses or is negotiated
away I still would try to get a public
option done the public option is is it's
a horribly milquetoast thing that is
barely better than what we have but it
is somewhat better so this is not me
being like a lame incremental it's just
I would try to do Medicare for all and I
would also try to get any kind of
advancement that I can if Republicans
control the Senate bearing in mind how
politics works in the United States yeah
yeah I totally agree with you I just I I
would just warn you a lot of people will
probably like progressive voice will
probably misinterpret this as we should
pass a public option instead of Medicare
for all and I it's very obviously if
you're listening to the words and
interpreting them correctly I you're
you're more so I'm not what I believe is
Bernie's plan to get Medicare for all
that yeah I mean listen I can't come
there is a whole cottage industry of
people who just like react to what I say
I don't watch any of it like I said my
time is spent reading nonfiction and
fiction books and you know playing music
and doing other stuff so I I fortunately
it sounds like because someone else
mentioned this earlier I don't have time
in my life to watch like other political
YouTube channels but people can have at
it I'll just keep doing my thing you
know yeah
any book recommendations before I head
off I just finished up Ronin Pharaohs
catch and kill and it's really good I
would recommend it all right I I want to
shout out my friend Avery Arbonne he
forgot to mention his name last time and
have a good day all right thank you very
much very much appreciate the call let
me say thanks to Nikko ssbm for
subscribing on Twitch prime says my last
prime sub with amazon prime student love
your content thank you also quake Z
seven eight nine zero has subscribed for
four months at Tier one says I love
Deepak and mister nano pod has
subscribed for three months says when
the missile start hitting
also FN wicked subscribed with prime
very much appreciate that thank you so
much and let me see if there was anybody
else that I needed to thank oh okay I've
gotten to the end of my time so thanks
to everybody for joining me I really
appreciate that wanted to get the first
stream of the year on the record oh let
me say thank you to Riley Potter before
I go Riley Potter has signed up on my
website and his new member number 20
thanks to everybody for for joining me I
am recommitted to lots of streams in
2020 and this is just the first one I'll
see everybody very soon